hey what's going on everybody um my name
is Tim I don't know if you guys know
about me at all I think people on Rob's
vlogging channel know about me but uh
I'm actually his twin brother so I
figured I would just stop in and and say
what's up yeah yeah that's cool that's
that's fun
I just need to that's one to say like
what's up just say hey but can you make
a video yeah then you can go ahead make
it prease okay okay what's going on guys
um yeah that was Tim he he'd like a
Peter my vlogging channel one point
people were freaking out cuz apparently
you guys didn't know that I had a twin
brother which I guess that kind of makes
sense Allah never told me buddy but um
yeah no okay so uh spider-man far from
home so um I was talking to the guys in
Sony and they're like you can do your
review on the 27th so I was like cool so
huge shout out to Derek he was he's like
the the guy that's like been helping me
navigate all the waters of like press
junkets and everything so there's a
really cool guy but ya know spider-man
far from home it's gonna change
everything
like it's it's it's it's going to change
everything and and here's the thing like
no spoilers right like I'm not gonna
spoil anything for you guys but but you
guys need to stay for the post-credits
right I mean that's a spoiler I feel
like it's common knowledge now you know
when it comes to like Marvel movies like
you have to stay for the post-credits
scene but it is it's it's it's gonna
change it's gonna [ __ ] like it's it
changes everything okay so it's exactly
what you would expect for a movie post
Avengers in game right like Iron Man all
that kind of cool stuff it's exactly
what you would expect but the character
development is absolutely amazing
right like because it's one of the funny
things for the character of Peter Parker
and really for the characters find a man
when it comes to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe like Iron Man was the face of
the MCU which kind of goes against
conventional wisdom right like you think
of Marvel you think it's spider-man for
the most part like like his face is like
he's like the face of the company right
like you go any look at comic books you
look at the old comic books on like the
cover where they give you like the issue
number and the release date all that
kind of stuff you see the little
spider-man face so like he's the face of
Marvel and then you look at the MCU and
it's like but it's Iran though
and I feel like with I am an out of the
picture in with the way this film went
it'll give Peter Parker a chance to
finally become like the face of the MCU
which as much as I love Ironman it's
kind of way that it should have been
right like spider-man should be the face
of the company now of course we know
that's not the case because of how
everything went down with like movie
rights all the kind of cool stuff when
the MCU first launched back in 2006-2007
but it's it's it's it's a solid film but
it's see here's the thing
people want to know about Mysterio right
like I wanna know that Mysterio so again
no spoilers here but you guys are not
ready for Mysterio like like you got
like here's to see here's the thing
like here's not here's the thing like I
look at Mysterio in the comics I'm like
okay so we only ever had like one good
moment and that was when he tricked
Wolverine and they're killing all the
x-men and old man Logan that's like the
one big moment he had throughout his
entire publication history in Marvel
Comics but in the movies it's it's
amazing like like the trailers don't do
him justice like I went into it thinking
I was basically gonna see a lot of what
I saw in the trailer and then I watched
the movie and I was like holy SH holy
crap this family-friendly almost like
holy crap um it was it was absolutely
bonkers up watching him do the kind of
stuff he did it was it was it was insane
this is so hard to make a review without
spoiling anything yeah you guys were not
ready for fur Mysterio uh as for
everything else or the supporting cast
with like Jacob battle on who plays who
plays Ned with regards to zendaya of
course who plays Michelle Jones um it's
cool I mean they're just kind of
continue on the way you expected them to
there is some development there and
especially after the events of in Game
two snap all that kind of cool stuff ah
there is some development there with him
Samuel Jackson like like as Nick Fury is
a lot more interesting he's a lot more
dynamic in this movie right because
traditionally Nick Fury has always been
like the super serious guy who like
never he's always like everything's a
big deal right like if Nick Fury went
til I order a cup of coffee from
Starbucks like it would be that cashiers
most intimidating experience ever you
know like he got this guy with an
eyepatch who's obviously seen some stuff
like since grisly looking guy and like
you get the impression that like if you
mess with his order like he's gonna kill
you like that's how it fuels like I
guess how Nick Fury always felt in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe ah but in this
movie like he's a lot
more interesting he's way more
interesting it's it's really really cool
so you definitely get to see some
development with him um
dare I say teetering on the edge of
spoilers here
I think he's gonna play a much bigger
role in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
going forward like a colossal role I
will also say this in terms of setting
the stage for the future of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe I think this movie
did it better than any movie that came
before it and I would say I think this
movie was probably as good if not maybe
a little bit better than like infinity
war and endgame I mean when you look at
like the story that's being told and
like how the events unfold I think it's
actually a little bit better in terms of
like grandiose battle scenes and all I
kind of cool stuff in game takes the
cake on that what I mean is there's you
know and infinity you get all these
really huge battles and those great big
huge events but in terms of like like
standalone movies based on a singular
character or intense ensemble of
characters I would say this is probably
the best Marvel Cinematic Universe movie
to date and it's it's it's nuts like I
understand like after seeing this movie
I understand why Amy Pascal the head of
Sony was like I wanna see Peter Parker
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe more
often um it's it's it's gonna be nuts I
am man because might be questioned after
infinity warned in game was like where
do they go from here right because like
it's the grandiose thing it's the 5-leaf
a nose and the Infinity stones and now
the whole infinity saga is over like
where do you go from here like leaving
out the x-men of the Fantastic Four
which is a whole nother set of events
like where do you go with like
spider-man and where do you go with like
Nick Fury and where do you go with like
the cast of characters that you see in
the movie like what happens next
there's there's a zillion things that
happen next there's a zillion things
that can happen next I will say that in
the movies you've seen so far with
infinity war an end game just because
things seemed like they were done does
not mean they work uh and yeah I will I
believe I will leave it at that
um in any event you are not gonna be
disappointed like if you got tickets to
this movie you are not going to be
disappointed you were gonna walk in out
of that theater with a smile on your
face it's a great closeout to the to the
events of an infinity war an in-game
it really does feel like the final film
of phase 3 I think it really did it
justice and ending out phase 3 and
really concluding like the last 10 years
um you're gonna walk out of theater with
a smile on your face and super hyped
about what it is it comes next because
it's it's it's like watching a TV show
right like if I walk down
like but like I need to know what
happens next though like it was it was
it was crazy
it's it's very very exciting um having
said that like once we get closer to the
release of the movie I will do a video
on like the post-credits scenes and what
they mean and all the kind of stuff to
expect uh because I will say that some
of the things that I that I call like
some of the things that I said in the
videos that I made I called like I got
it right like I like something like not
even tell you what it is like they're
laying in the videos that I made about
where they're gonna go in the future of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe
I called that [ __ ] so I'm very excited
about it because I was right but anyway
we're being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end and yeah I will
catch you all later
[Music]